[Applause]
[Music]
the article has landed
New York's next political to top
political consulting firms said that I
can pretty much write my own ticket I
cannot wait
Cena due to my family I can't believe I
forgot
it says colosso toys this one left we
did it
Hey what are you doing that was mine I
put my name on the box bigger I could
just come back for it later you know
your name is on it
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas did you
lie to that little girl you don't even
know me to judge me you're right
looks like I don't know you at all
anymore
that grandma this is Julie hello Julie
hope you're hungry
I made something special for you Miss
Georgia told you oh yes but odd 6 do
family tradition and torch her a hole in
one bowl I just picked this up last week
and a charity auction for the Audubon
Society what do you think it's bad it
should be named why cocktails should be
banned at charity auctions I can't lie
he looks pretty darn good in this cover
as well doesn't where do you think you
got that room it's obvious that it comes
from me mr. Bowman over $24,000 and
veneers didn't hurt though a little
Botox between the brows Gillian even
found a picture of my wedding dress just
to see what you think I can't lie she
was a bride
oh my god get out of there goal
I mean since Jillian's being so honest
we are actually married
[Music]
you